[Music]
model actress and fashion royalty Cara
Delevingne has been turning heads on red
carpets and runways for years
known for her edgy style Cara Rose to
Fame in 2012 after winning model of the
year at the British fashion Awards a
title she swept again two years later
becoming a face for everyone from
Victoria's Secret to Chanel to Burberry
despite taking a Hiatus for modeling
Cara has been on her comeback tour this
year she was vogue's April cover star
stole the show at the Oscars and was one
of the most anticipated arrivals at the
Met Gala as one of Carl lagerfeld's most
beloved Muses speaking of them
Conan gray also turned heads at this
year's Met Gala alongside balmon
designer Olivier Rustin while he might
be a rising star in the music industry
Conan solidified his place as a style
star his ability to blend genres extends
beyond music as he combines elements of
Street Wear vintage and gender-neutral
fashion well from a red carpet staple to
a red carpet statement
Sam Smith is a global Superstar who has
redefined gender Norms with courageous
Couture in looks that are daring
fearless and fun whether it's a
performance or music video
[Music]
you can count on them to serve viral
looks from the Brit Awards to the
Grammys
Stephanie Shu made her mark on the award
circuit as a first-time Oscar nominee
after stealing our hearts in everything
everywhere all at once the queer actress
brought her infectious energy into her
fashion choices
thank you
with a mix of vibrant colors patterns
and accessories Stephanie continues to
embrace her unique identity through
fashion